sie ließen
hallo ich bin's elli von salis torten
welt und das ist wie heißt du sara und
samira ist meine kleine tochter und wir
werden heute eine kleine süßigkeit
backen die man eben gut mit kindern
backen kann und vor allen dingen für
kinder backen kann bei uns gibt es
nämlich heute richtig leckere bananen
muffins die dann später als rentiere
dekoriert werden und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal die zutaten für den
teig wir brauchen zwei bananen 1 120
gramm zucker 250 gramm mehl 80 gramm öl
ich habe hier in sonnenblumenöl 50 gramm
schokostreusel hier habe ich zwei
teelöffel backpulver unten vier
teelöffel lebkuchengewürz hier habe ich
150 gramm joghurt creme und 100
milliliter milch zuerst nehmen wir jetzt
die bananen und die dürfen richtig reif
sein denn dann sind sie richtig schön
süß und die werden jetzt geschält schale
hier rein und jetzt werden die banane
noch zerdrückt das geht am besten mit
seinem kartoffelstampf oder mit einer
gabel
danach weiter und ich werde jetzt in der
zwischenzeit schon mal das ei in die
rührschüssel geben
gebt dem zucker mit dazu und verrührt es
einfach bis es richtig schön cremig ist
aber jetzt gebe ich hier die bananen mit
seiner mischung die herrscher richtig
schön verrückt
und wenn das kurz verrührt es gehen wir
jetzt noch die restlichen zutaten mit
dazu zuerst mal das öl dann die
schokostreusel das backpulver ruhig hier
kurz mit dem mehl und auch gleich die
nuss nougat creme und es wird jetzt kurz
verrühren und ich gebe dann nur so viel
milch mit dazu dass es eben ein
geschmeidiger teig wird
und ich nehme jetzt 1 portion ehre und
portioniert den teig in meine zwölf
machen förmchen
und so werden die muffins jetzt bei 180
grad für etwa 20 minuten gebacken und
danach lassen wir sie komplett abkühlen
die machen sind jetzt gebacken und
abgekühlt und so sehen sie jetzt aus und
hier riecht auch schon richtig gut denn
die bananen muffins schmecken sehr
lecker und wir werden uns jetzt um die
dekoration kümmern und zwar brauche ich
jetzt für die dekoration ein paar
salzbrezeln dann hier ein paar schoko
trox bunte hier habe ich zucker augen
die zucker augen gibt sich bringen es
bei uns im shop
hier habe ich ein paar kekse und zwar
sind die vorne mit schokolade und hinten
einfach so ein bisschen wird jetzt könnt
ihr entweder so keksen oder einfach
andere kekse und damit die dekoration
gleich an den muffins hält muss ich noch
ein frosting machen und für das frosting
brauche ich 100 gramm nuss-nougat-creme
100 gramm frischkäse und 50 gramm butter
ich werde jetzt erstmal das frosting
herstellen und früher einfach alle
zutaten miteinander
das wird jetzt kurz miteinander verrührt
und bei diesen frostigen kann man echt
nichts falsch machen
das stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite und
bereit kurz die muffins vor und zwar
sind sehen die muffins perfekt aus
perfekt heißt sie sind oben gewölbt aber
weil ich da jetzt noch die deko
draufsetzen will schneide ich mir diese
werbung jetzt ein bisschen rund haben
damit sie gerade werden
den rest müsste übrigens nicht
wegschmeißen denkt könnte einfach weiter
verwenden zum beispiel zu cake pops oder
nachstehend einfach auch mal probieren
ok jetzt nehme ich mir meine muffins und
mein frosting und geht jetzt immer so
ein bisschen frosting auf einen muffin
und für die dekoration den ich mir jetzt
so einen keks ihr könnt auch das casting
zum beispiel bisschen dicker auftragen
auch hat ein bisschen mehr leckere creme
drauf und jetzt setzt sich hier den keks
trauen
das wird jetzt gleich die mundpartie
neben mehr zwei augen
mit ein bisschen creme klebe ich jetzt
noch eine nase drauf
rudolph hatte eigentlich eine rote nase
bei mir hat er jetzt eine pinkfarbene
nase und jetzt brauchen wir noch das 1
gb
das könnte einfach so drauf haben und so
haben wir dann ein schönes geschirr
kaputt
du darfst es auch
die
so sehen jetzt unsere fertigen rentiere
aus und ich finde sie sind richtig
hübsch und vor allen dingen macht auch
richtig viel spaß mit den kindern diese
muffins zu dekorieren habt ihr auch spaß
gemacht genau und genauso lecker sind
die muffins auch denn der bananen
rührteig ich richtig schön saftig und
durch die anderen zutaten also snogard
creme und so weiter auch richtig lecker
das rezept und die genaue anleitung gibt
es auch noch einmal zum nachlesen auf
verließ - flotte und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachhaken und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder bis
bald
übrigens findet ihr alle produkte die
ich heute benutzt habe auch bei mir im
shop auf cds - shop.de und ich wünsche
euch jetzt einen noch eine richtig
schöne besinnliche weihnachtszeit
genießt die zeit mit euren freunden mit
eurer familie bis bald